michel canet vcc soixante deux éoliennes
dont l'impact est c'est vrai à
prévisible on ne sait pas ce que ça va
donner
est ce que ça vaut la peine de perdre
les coquilles saint jacques on en aura -
et des pêcheurs qui auront moins
d'emplois alors frédéric taddeï soyons
clairs moi j'adore la coquille
saint-jacques et je veux saluer la
démarche des pêcheurs de la baie de
saint brieuc elle est formidable en
termes d'exemplarité pour ce qui
concerne la préservation et la gestion
de la ressource il n'y a pas de
quasiment pas d'équivalent de démarches
aussi
je dirais à un salut est telle que celle
là simplement moi je pense que l'on peut
concilier l'ensemble des enjeux le tout
est effectivement ce parc éolien ne soit
pas sur les zones les plus denses e pour
la coquille elles ne sont en aucune
aucune des éoliennes prévues dès sur la
zone primaire de de la coquille saint
jacques une partie 15% serait sur la
zone secondaire c'est-à-dire là où il ya
un peu moins de deux outils sa gêne mais
finalement moi je me dis que les récifs
c'est à dire ce que l'on peut mettre en
mer des zones dans lesquelles
il faut limiter la pêche ça peut être
extrêmement prolifique pour la gestion
de la ressource aussi puisque ça permet
d'avoir des autres ou la région
justement peut se reproduire plus
facilement et ainsi faire en sorte que
la la ressource soit plus abondante eu
de match quoique il faut vraiment que
l'on gère comme jamais mais disons le
clairement
l'essentiel du parc éolien n'affecte pas
les zones de pêche s'en prennent
l'ensemble des pêcheurs de la coquille
saint jacques sur la baie de saint
brieuc
[Musique]